in early december bettor.com ceo vishal
garg fired about 900 employees via zoom
and i do not do not want to do this
the last time i did it i cried
but this wasn't the first time the tech
leader landed in hot water for his
leadership style a 2020 forbes
investigation found that better
employees have long complained about
garg's leadership and ongoing lawsuits
accuse garg or entities he controls of
improper and even fraudulent activities
at two prior business ventures
including allegations of
misappropriating tens of millions of
dollars
vishal garg was born in india and moved
to queens with his family in his early
childhood as a teen in new york he
attended the prestigious stuyvesant high
school and then nyu
a serial entrepreneur garg ran a few
companies until he founded better.com in
2013.
so beta has had a lot of success and and
it obviously hit a nerve especially
among uh home buyers because going
through the the mortgage process is such
a pain and it is really a byzantine sort
of process that you know really was
right for disrupting so when beta came
in and said you know we can offer you
pre-approval on loans within you know a
few minutes it really sort of changed
the space and as a result of that you
know it became incredibly successful
investors look to pour in you know
hundreds of millions of dollars and by
the end of 2020 the company is valued at
four billion dollars which really you
know paved the way for vishal to be seen
as quite a revolutionary uh fintech
leader better success prompted forbes
reporters to look into the successful
startup and its founder and ceo what
they found were lawsuits that had
followed garg for years there was
allegations of fraud misappropriation of
funds
and reaching a fiduciary duties there
was also an allegation that garg had
used misappropriated funds to
seed and fund better as it started
going back in into garg's history we
found that he had a former friend that
he'd met at stevenson high school named
raza khan and they had been you know
close friends they went to nyu together
and after
graduating from college they started a
company called my rich uncle which was a
very successful student loan provider in
the early 2000s it became one of the
largest you know student loan providers
in the country
until the financial crash in 2008 cut
off access to more funding so the
company had to shut down
shortly after gargan khan started eifc
which managed private student loans in
mortgage-backed securities they had some
success in that but this is about the
time when their relationship started to
fall apart and
raiza filed a lawsuit against vishal
garg accusing him of misappropriating uh
several million dollars from the company
at the same time michelle counter sued
raza and
basically the two men became locked in a
years-long legal dispute over
how money was used at the ifc as the
court battle drew on it became so bitter
that during one deposition uh vishal
actually threatened to burn raza alive
garg apologized for his outburst but
denies khan's claim but garg has also
been accused by investors of mismanaging
funds related to mortgage portfolios
in 2011 garg recruited investors to take
over a mortgage portfolio through a
series of businesses set up in the
cayman islands the plan was to use
eifc's software to identify toxic
mortgages then reap huge settlements
from the banks that issued them
the investors which include pimco and
goldman sachs accuse garg of moving
settlement money into accounts he
controls instead of paying out the funds
to investors the total sum that garx
companies allegedly did not disclose to
debtors remains unclear though filings
in the ongoing case pegged a figure in
the tens of millions of dollars
garg himself is not being sued but is
identified in court filings as the
person in control of the entities named
as defendants so after our investigation
was published in 2020 the company only
grew from there and this
shore the company to effectively go
public by the end of 2021 and everything
looked quite sunny for the company
until the day after they announced that
funding round um
i come to you with
not great news
pandemonium ensued and
after these news reports came out the
shah then went on to disparage many of
these employees to the existing
employees and you know calling them lazy
following the controversy reports began
to circulate about garg's treatment of
employees and comments he's made about
bettors investors forbes also reported
conflicts of interest garg has in
relation to better namely that he owns
or holds a majority stake in companies
that contract with better.com finally
better announced that garg would be
stepping back as ceo and he was placed
on indefinite leave better also decided
to delay its planned spac merger until
the show guy really embodied what it
meant to be a machismo uh you know tech
ceo you know from people who i've spoken
to sitting across the table from vishal
he could you know sell ice to eskimos
like he was an incredibly charming man
and this is this is a characteristic
that is shared by
a lot of these successful tech
entrepreneurs they also you know do have
a high tolerance for risk and sometimes
that that tolerance for risk
does end in legal medicine and it did
come as little surprise to us that
michelle ended up in the scenario that
he is in now
[Music]